time for today's bar chart the day Swiss
investors will never forget where were
you
10:30 a.m. Swiss Time on Thursday
January the 15th when the SNB the Swiss
National Bank ended the euro franc cap
and lower deposit rates to minus 75
basis points I want to look at the
impact on the Swiss stock market on the
benchmark Swiss market index now in the
90 minutes this is a 1-day chart to
Thursday chart in the 90 minutes running
up to the SMB announcement top left-hand
corner of your screen
Swiss docks we're trading higher up as
much as 0.9%
look at the cliff for look at the
precipice that was 10:30 a.m. Swiss time
9:30 London time this chart by the way
is in London time the s/m I then
embarked on a two-hour 13.7 percent
decline that's the biggest since records
began in July 1988 from 11:30 the low
here over the next 5 hours to the right
hand corner of your screen the SM I
recovered 5% of those losses it still
entered the day down by 8 point 7
percent its biggest drop since October
the 16th 1989 here's the killer stat in
one day a hundred billion Swiss francs
the value that's a hundred and fifteen
billion dollars have been wiped off the
SMI now there are 20 stocks on the SMI
for a large part of the day all 20
traded lower after the SNP announcement
at the close only one stock Swisscom
finished the day high it grows one
percent at one stage it was down by 3%
out of Switzerland's biggest three
companies listen to this Novartis nine
percent lower it lost 23 billion Swiss
francs of its value rosh eight percent
lower it lost fifteen billion Swiss
francs of its market value Nestle down
by six percent it lost 15 billion Swiss
francs evaluation the stock that fell
the most though was what
group it plummeted by 16% its biggest
forever losing 4 billion Swiss francs
evaluation I want to finish with the
words of the chief executive officer of
swatch group NIC Hayek he commented on
the snv's moved to remove the euro franc
cap words fail me he said today's SMB
action is a tsunami for the export
industry and for tourism and finally for
the entire country Thursday January the
15th 2015 the day Swiss investors will
never forget